hey crazies for 250 years we treated
gravity as if it was a force like any
other that model explained both falling
on earth and orbits in space
it seemed Universal but about a century
ago we learned that model is wrong
gravity is actually curvature of
space-time and most of the gravity we
experience on earth is curvature in time
yes time can curve this episode was made
possible by generous supporters on
patreon to be fair I can understand if
you're shocked or confused right now or
golf
you can probably picture some kind of
space curvature it's not a huge stretch
but time curvature what does that even
mean
it's a fair question so let's start with
a simple experiment see we've got a tall
building like really tall it's poking
out into space we're ignoring any
engineering difficulties just just go
with it
on the ground floor there's a photon
launcher it sends out a photon every
second on the top floor there's a photon
timer it receives the photons and
measures the time between them if we
assume an absolute time frame for
everyone and everything in the universe
which is certainly what our intuitions
tell us to do we'd expect the photon
timer to receive a photon every second
but that's not what happens the photon
timer actually receives a photon every
one point zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero one seconds yes I
know that's a hundredth of a nanosecond
difference but it's still a difference
that means clocks on the top floor of a
building tick just a tiny bit faster
than clocks on the ground floor when two
independent clocks tick at different
rates we call that time dilation I would
have called the time variation instead
cuz it isn't actually dilating but so be
it
the point is time passes at different
rates in different places for example
time passes more slowly the closer you
are to the earth
the earth causes it that's what time
curvature looks like around the earth
that's how it's perceived I know right
time dilation is real and it matters our
GPS network would fail rather quickly if
we didn't account for it within a day of
turning it on your location would have a
seven-mile error but it gets even
crazier than that the type of time
dilation involved in that building
experiment is called gravitational time
dilation not because it comes from
gravity but because it causes gravity I
know that sounds weird but but hear me
out just for a minute
forget everything you know about gravity
imagine it doesn't exist in that
imaginary world there's no reason for
this world to fall he just floats there
that's Newton's laws at play
no one balanced force means no
acceleration no acceleration means if he
wasn't already moving he's not gonna
start now next let's say there's time
dilation caused by the earth
remember time passes at different rates
in different places the heights of the
clocks don't have to be that different
though any difference will do so imagine
we attach two clocks to a squirrel one
on his head and one on his feet they
should tick at different rates - the
difference isn't that much in fact it's
even smaller than it was for the
building it's only an extra for one
hundredths of a femtosecond at the head
for every whole second - the feet but
any difference will do no matter how
small
unfortunately watching clocks tick
doesn't actually give us the right
intuition let's try something a little
different if we only consider the
up-and-down direction that frees up the
sideways direction for something else
like time for example this is just a
space versus time graph nothing too
crazy we've been looking at graphs like
that for hundreds of years
to look for patterns in motion except
the squirrel isn't moving remember we're
still in that imaginary world with no
force of gravity that means we expect
this squirrel to be at the same height
at all times he has no reason to fall to
the ground
or does he let's take everything we've
learned so far and put it all together
the squirrel is hovering above the earth
and space but it's moving forward in
time I mean everything is moving through
time but we also know time flows at
different rates in different places you
could think of it like a flow gradient
around the earth and what happens when
there's a gradient stuff gradients are
the reason that anything happens ever oh
the squirrels head moves faster through
time than his feet this gradually turns
his motion arrow what we call the four
velocity over time it points more and
more toward the earth the squirrel falls
to the ground
simply because time dilation exists
surprise we just predicted gravity this
whole time we've been imagining a
universe without a force of gravity but
as long as time passes at different
rates in different places things will
fall anyway gravity exists even if we
don't treat it as a force why does the
squirrel fall because there's a flow
gradient in time why does the moon orbit
the earth because there's a flow
gradient in time the weird universe
we've been imagining is our universe
whoa dude to be clear though it's not
time itself that's flowing time doesn't
do that and neither does space the flow
you're seeing in this animation it's
just there to give you intuition I've
just replaced the ticking clocks with a
bunch of imaginary point particles so
wait what about point particles what
about it if they feel gravity sure how
do they feel that time gradient flow
thingy they don't have any size
well because calculus while we consider
all these elementary particles to be
points with no size we don't actually
know that's true they're just smaller
than we can measure but even if they are
points with no size the math doesn't
treat them that way if we shrink this
world down to subatomic scales the two
clocks get closer and closer but they're
never at exactly the same place and
they're never ticking at exactly the
same rate
there are always two clocks sometimes
they're just infinitesimally close to
each other so where does gravity come
from it comes from time dilation that's
the idea that time passes at different
rates in different places large masses
like the earth don't exert a force they
just make time pass more slowly nearby
them this creates a gradient in the flow
of time which bends space-time paths
gravity is just time curving into space
time is more fundamental than gravity so
got any questions about gravity please
ask in the comments thanks for liking
and sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy several of you
asked about electron orbits in the last
video no electrons do not orbit in
orbital is not an orbit it's a visual
representation of the probabilistic
existence of quantum particles anyway
thanks for watching